Welcome back, in the first two lessons
you learned how to build great inputs.
In the last lesson you
practiced building great force.
Along the way you probably noticed
that building great experiences for
your mobile users has been
a major theme of this course.
>> Yes, and that's because it can be
a lot more difficult to build the really
fantastic experience for them.
When users choose to
interact with you app,
it should respond to that touch
in intuitive and beautiful ways.
And that's what you'll
learn in this lesson.
>> You'll fix a few sites that badly
need your help with some better
touch events.
And at the end of it you'll be
given this courses project.
If you feel like you need more practice
designing websites for mobile, I highly
recommend checking out the course called
Responsive Web Design Fundamentals.
Which I teach alongside Etos
colleague from Google Pete Lepage.
You can find a link to it
in the instructor notes.
>> Great, first thing first, I want
you to see why touch events matter.